une production du studio sfr
nous sans filtre présenté par kiss me le
podcast où on parle de ce qu'ont vécu
nos invités date seach ph quand tu es
avec moi dôme plants et semis collabore
à chaque mois avec quatre à six artistes
un de partout dans le monde pour créer
des collections uniques et originales de
15 cellulaire aller sur leur site web
dans la collection artistes pour voir
les oeuvres d'art qui ont été créés ces
des quantités limitées donc évidemment
dépêchez vous puis pour vrai aller voir
les caisses parce que c'est
extraordinaire vous allez aussi pouvoir
en apprendre plus sur les artistes qui
ont collaboré avec kiss me utiliser le
code promo sf 15 pour 15 % de rabais sur
les produits qasmi d'hommes set cette
semaine d'un grand plaisir de recevoir
andré en lice honnête qui en fait la
personne qu'on appelle quand qu'on veut
parler de la question d'accès à
l'avortement aux états unis ou n'importe
où en fait selon une spécialiste de ce
fait leur affaire maintenance au
doctorat sur la question a
principalement au sud des états unis
est aussi chercheur à la chaire raoul
dandurand est l'échangé de cours à
l'uqam et c'était vraiment super
intéressante dans la trame plus sur ce
sujet le qui comme je le disais
extrêmement important et aussi fragile
en fait l'accès à l'avortement c'est
qu'on se rend compte dans les dernières
semaines fait avec des nouveaux projets
de loi en fait des nouvelles lois qui
sont passés au texas puis curieux un
recul en fait c'est accélère on essaie
de comprendre un peu qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est quoi cette loi le qu'est ce
que la cour suprême à jouer là-dedans on
publie pas l'historique aussi de l'accès
à l'avortement aux états unis c'était
vraiment super passionnant vraiment
l'impression de maintenant mieux
comprendre le sujet on la remercie
énormément ouais on a aussi développé
sur les dangers de la pente glissante
que j'en connais pas on n'est pas l'abri
si au canada a fait dix plus importants
rester informé sur ces questions là
on va les remercier nos commanditaires
avant de vous laisser écouter la
conversation donc bon paquet bonne
écoute le podcast cette semaine et
présenté par nos qui rend à michigan
state cette semaine je peux pas compter
sur mes deux mains les fois où est-ce
qu'ils ne souhaitent complimenter sur
mon parfum je faisais un petit peu de
service aux tables pour aider une amie
qui à chaque fois penché par dessus des
clients surtout les clients nous et où
vous vous sentez bon ben c'est à cause
que j'avais mon parfum hui fine de même
skate c'est vraiment une odeur douce
agrumes et d'hommes chez que si moi je
leur fais pas tu le portrait sûrement il
faudrait parce que tu veux pas qu'on
fasse la même chose mais je vous le dis
de 6 est une fille voulait offrir sur un
tube à une connaissance un frère une
odeur masculine mais en subtilité
progrès c'est incroyable d'autres sites
les produits indiqués peut on les adore
mouche 2 utilise tous que ce soit le
tournoi qui soit le crop préserver que
ce soit le
de l'homme au cameroun l'endroit 4.0 qui
leur avons créé électrique mais ce que
quand on est le récit
il va tellement bien que moi je les
utilise à toutes les sauces j'utilise
pour toutes sortes d'utilisations qui
j'ai récemment eu une bulle au cerveau
que je n'aime pas une vraie coupe de
cheveux incroyable je ne servais des
exploits comme vous pouvez voir ici
comment les galaxies sont en audio allez
voir la vidéo ça vaut la peine moi je
trouve ça incroyablement bon c'est la
plus belle coupe que j'ai eu dans ma vie
fille d i 2 je les fais avec mon band
skype mais on voit que le travail est
bien fait ça a été passé des pauvres
lectrique qui vaut aussi bien que sur le
je vous l'assuré regarder quand mayer
6-2 tout cas si vous voulez avoir une
tête de merde comme dom vous pouvez
acheter n'importe quel produit indiqué
avec le code promo sans filtre pour 20%
de rabais of plus la livraison gratuite
sauter là dessus comme du petit pain
chaud juste un petit mot pour dire que
notre page pq on est encore active pour
3 dollars par mois vous avez accès à
tous les podcasts en avance notamment
deux qui vont être là dans les
prochaines heures un avec jean philippe
wauthier et un autre avec laurent turcot
en plus aux pitchouns ont fait du
contenu bonus qu'on pût contenu
supplémentaire en fait après chaque parc
à ce qu'on fait on fait ce qu'on appelle
un encore moins un filtre qu'on fait
comme 20 30 minutes juste m'occuper h on
parle de ce qui va se passer nos
impressions sur le podcast on développe
mousse des puits ont très bien content
que vous vous joignez à nous et que vous
laissez des commentaires que vous
participez à la discussion avec les
wallons mouillé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
carole merci beaucoup d'être là
oui ça va bien vous deux oui supporte
pas rédaction en ce moment oui en grosse
rédaction de la comédie
c'est différent de toutes les autres
étapes du dr parce que c'est traité
comme un peu en isolement c'était dans
ta bulle d'écriture puis on dirait qu
avec la coved qui de travailler de la
maison ça ajoute
même temps c'est super stimulant parce
que ma recherche avait quand même des
composants très actuel puis à aix
inscrivent un peu comme à la limite
entre l'activisme pile l'académique fixé
c'est aussi motivant de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ça le salaire n'est pas que
ça leur potentiel
quand tu dis que c'est d'actualité ça
allait beaucoup le wesh travail sur les
textes on est donc dans les dernières
semaines ça a été très très actuel -
puis on s'en est parlé avant dans notre
nombre de gens qui nous écoutent le
sujet de sa thèse moutons c'est quoi moi
je travaille sur l'accès des femmes
maintenant américaine à l'avortement
dans quatre états frontaliers donc le
texte date laquelle fournit la
pennsylvanie et new york
fixé c'est 1 6% fêtes comble est
complète recevoir jadida s'est
évidemment moi j'ai essayé de
c'est quand même avant qu avant chaque
podcast lorsqu'on parle d'un sujet que
ben que je maîtrise pas que je connais
mal ou que je me rends compte que je
connais mal me trompe décide de
comprendre qu'est ce qui s'était passé
il ya quelques semaines et exerce pis
force est d'admettre que j'ai de la
difficulté à comprendre exactement c'est
quoi qui s'est passé parce que
d'un côté il y avait pire on va tout
déplier seul et maintenant côté avait le
fait que la loi est
anticonstitutionnelle mais que
finalement ce des camions comme trouver
une façon de contourner ça pour pour
empêcher ou ou restreindre le droit à
l'avortement puis et puis je te mêler un
peu dans tout ça fait que j'aimerais ça
con qu'on explique ça mais en commençant
par comment est ce que en commençant par
l'histoire du droit à l'avortement
aux états unis parce que où dans le
monde entier mais falloir remonter quand
même plusieurs années pour l'accès au
droit à l'avortement à aux états unis
parce qu en fait lorsqu'on regarde
historiquement on voit que l'avortement
a déjà été légal avant 1973 aux états
unis dans le fond ce qui est arrivé
c'est que l'avortement donc c'était une
pratique qui qui étaient là qui
existaient mais s'était majoritairement
des des mid wild donc des sages femmes
qui accompagnaient les femmes à travers
ce processus là d'avortement et il faut
préciser qu'à ce moment là on parle des
années 1800 les sages femmes étaient
notamment les femmes afro américaine qu
il ya eu un mouvement de ressac en fait
pas juste les avortements exploser à ce
moment-là c'était pas des procédures
chirurgicales
avancé le nom ce n'est pas comme
aujourd'hui mais on parle pas non plus
d'avortements dans des souterrains qui
mené à des décès à profusion le dolphin
vraiment c'est une pratique qui était
médical qui était reconnue qui était
légal mais que c'était les sages femmes
qui accompagnaient donc les femmes à
travers cette procédure le collège des
médecins qui voyait donc cette
augmentation le du rôle des sages femmes
dans la santé reproductive des femmes
qui a eu certain ressac de la part du
collège des médecins puis tout
l'argumentaire par rapport à ce que le
foetus et la possibilité d'avorter il ya
eu donc un effet domino à partir de la
deuxième moitié des années 1800 ou les
étangs au criminaliser l'avortement pour
une première fois est-ce que d'un site
dans cette réticence du collège des
médecins il y avait aussi le fait que
comme tous mentionnaient les sages
femmes étaient principalement froid
américaine oui je le précisais pour
doc c'était une composante qui était à
la fois un enjeu lié au dynamique
raciale mais également par rapport aux
enjeux de reproduction puis aux enjeux
de natalité des femmes et donc on en
arrive au début des années 1900 avec une
carte des états unis ou majoritairement
tous les états ont criminalisé la
pratique de l'avortement
par contre ça veut pas dire que parce
qu'on criminalise quelque chose que plus
de demande donc qu'on parle d'avortement
qu'on parle de pratiquement n'importe
quoi d'autre ce qui fait qu'il y avait
quand même des demandes qui avaient des
réseaux souterrains qui se sont créés
pour permettre l'accès à l'avortement
chez les femmes et c'est là où on parle
de lorsqu'on fait référence à la
situation pourrir au viread qu'on fait
pour revenir l'eau avortements
clandestins mais c'est à cette période
là qu'on fait référence où les
avortements étaient souvent fait dans
des sous sols dans des conditions qui
étaient peu sanitaires et qui mettaient
en danger les vies des femmes parce
qu'il y avait des blessés à chaque année
liée à des avortements clandestins
la fameuse image du cintre pour pour les
pour tenir les vêtements exactement oui
les dons et autres méthodes qui
inquiété particulièrement dangereuse et
à partir des gens du milieu des années
1920 1950 1960 par le biais d autres
revendications pour la ligue droits
sexuels et reproductifs aux états unis
notamment la pilule contraceptive on a
vu un nouveau discours qui a émergé dans
certains états qui faisait une
distinction les avortements
thérapeutiques et les avortements choisi
et à partir de ce moment là il ya
plusieurs états qui ont dit on veut
légaliser les avortements dit
thérapeutique donc suite au violent à
l'inceste et pour des raisons médicales
également et ce qui est intéressant
lorsqu'on regarde l'histoire du droit à
l'avortement aux etats-unis c'est qu'on
voit que certains des états qui ont
légalisé pendant cette période assez des
états qui aujourd'hui sont très
restrictifs on peut penser au
mississippi où il reste une seule
clinique d'avortement aujourd'hui mais
qui était précurseur dans la
légalisation de l'avortement
thérapeutique parce qu'on faisait
vraiment une distinction entre
thérapeutique est choisi mais après à
travers le temps qu'il est le disco
rapidement de vue d état de fait nous on
veut légaliser pour aussi choisi parce
que c'est quoi vraiment la différence en
thérapeutique de choisy sur l'acte comme
teigne en octobre exactement voilà et ça
nous a menés donc à la contestation qui
a permis la légalisation de l'avortement
à travers le territoire des etats-unis
en 1973 d'enrobé wade qui mettait en
cause une loi du texas dont qui
interdisait l'accès à l'avortement et où
django donc demandé à avoir accès à
l'avortement pour des raisons choisi et
non pas pour des raisons thérapeutiques
et la cour suprême a donc légaliser
l'avortement à ce moment là ce ce col de
rovi wade en moi j'ai vu se passer quand
ça se passe et autres exagéré us à
passer
partout sur mon fils d'actualité si tout
le monde faisait référence à ça mais
j'ai j'avais honnêtement aucune idée de
quoi on parle et rit puis le jeu
monsieur j'essayais de m'informer encore
une fois difficile de
saint mary's et d'études de faire une
somme de tout ça via wikipedia dati fait
c'est quoi exactement que c'est passé
l'ordre dans cette situation dans le cas
de robin mais dans le fond on s'inscrit
encore une fois dans une suite de
décisions juridiques sur les droits
reproductifs dont convenait de légaliser
dix ans plus tôt l' accès à la pilule
contraceptive pour tout le monde on
avait légalisé également par la suite
l'accès à la pilule contraceptive pour
les couples non mariés et la danse est
dans ces deux décisions là en fait on
appuyait la décision sur un droit à la
vie privée c'est à dire que ce qui se
passe dans votre chambre à coucher c'est
vos affaires le gouvernement n'a pas à
s'immiscer dans ce qui se passe dans cet
espace privé là et lorsque les juges ont
eu donc les arguments pour et contre la
légalisation du droit à l'avortement
dans la cause de robin wales ce sur quoi
ils se sont appuyés ses précédents la
par rapport au droit à la vie privée et
ils ont dit bah en fait l'accès à
l'avortement sa relève également du
droit à la vie privée par rapport à
votre santé reproductive et le
gouvernement ne pas s'immiscer dans le
bureau du médecin dans lequel je décide
si oui ou non il y a
une volonté de mettre un terme à une
grossesse par contre la cour suprême a
le puisque les juges en fait c'est
qu'ils ont divisé la grossesse en trois
trimestres qui ont dit pendant le
premier trimestre va à peu près jusqu'à
la 14e semaine layton ne peut absolument
pas s'immiscer dans cette décision dont
pied qui vit la famille sont médecins
choisissent ce qui est bon pour la femme
ensuite le deuxième trimestre on dit
durant ce trimestre là il ya comme un on
n'en peut plus avancer dans la grossesse
on veut jusqu'à à peu près la 24e
semaine qui est le point de viabilité et
on dit durant cette période là donc
l'état pur peut encadrer la pratique à
l'avortement de façon à préserver la
santé de la femme donc de mettre des
règles un peu plus serré sur comment
dans quelles conditions l'avortement
peut se
faire et ensuite durant le troisième
trimestre donc qui va au delà de la 24e
semaine ont-ils l'état au maintenant des
intérêts dans la viabilité du foetus et
peu décidé d'interdire l'avortement deux
parties intérêt à ce que le foetus
arrive donc à terme et soit un citoyen
de sainte rita donc ce que rovio est
bien faire en séparant en trois
trimestres et de d'encadrer qu'est ce
que les états peuvent faire est de
mettre dans le fond une barre au point
de viabilité et dire avant le point de
viabilité c'est interdit de
d'enlever tout accès à l'avortement
après le point de viabilité par contre
c'est possible de le faire puis ça ça va
revenir
pertinents dans ce qui s'est passé
dernièrement le c3 et apple plus le
point de viabilité mais pourquoi est ce
que le cas de janeiro est en était un
qui a fait ce changement est ce qu a eu
d'autres
d'autres situations comme ceux qui ont
juste pas eu l'impact de celles au fil
du temps il ya eu plus tôt d'autres
tentatives de légaliser l'avortement
mais au niveau de l'échelle nationale on
s'inscrit aussi dans un contexte comme
je le mentionnais il ya eu des
légalisations dans certains états donc
un peu si on veut faire un parallèle
avec les mariages homosexuels
la cour suprême a fini par se prononcer
parce qu'il y avait plusieurs états qui
l'avait déjà légalisé sur leur
territoire donc un des éléments de
justification aussi d'enrobé wade c'est
à dire en fait on a actuellement une
carte qui est complètement disparates en
termes d'accessibilité donc si vous
habitez en californie versus haute
examinait vous avez deux droits qui sont
différents donc on avait comme objectif
d'aplanir ces disparités géographiques
des droits et de dire ben on a déjà des
états qui légalise et le côté du pur
convaincu la cour que c'était dans le
meilleur intérêt que de légaliser le
droit comme c'est égaliser à 113 par la
cour suprême comment ça se fait ce que
moi j'ai l'impression que c'est toujours
un débat qui peut régler aux états unis
mais c'est toujours quelque chose qui
inquiète qui constamment remis sur la
table
questionné redébattu puis donc puis l'on
le veuille ou chamakh est exaucé on
essaie de contourner ou de renverser un
peu cette décision l'homme est ce que
c'est la première fois qu'ils comme ceux
qui arrivent depuis 113 où c'est arrivé
plus à fond non en fait peu d'années
après 1973 donc en 1989 la cour a eu à
se reprocher sur une autre cause liés à
l'avortement et après
l'évaluation de
cette cause là on fait de la cour
suprême à donner davantage de pouvoirs
aux états pour légiférer donc durant le
troisième trimestre on peut encadrer
davantage la pratique de l'avortement et
à partir de ce moment là on a vu le
vraiment un monte de l'activisme au
niveau des états qui était contre le
droit à l'avortement de dire bob et si
on ne peut pas l'interdire complètement
on veut tranquillement adopter des lois
qui en fait ont entraîné la situation
qu'on a aujourd'hui où le droit à
l'avortement existe encore aux états
unis mais il est érodée à un point mou
dans certains et à l'accessibilité est
complètement est
inexistant ce nouveau compteur depuis
une seule clinique ex donc c'est en
limitent l'accès serait donc ce soit
pratiquement impossible de faire avorter
voilà est encore là lorsque une seule
clinique par exemple au mississippi mais
ça dépend beaucoup de votre statut
socioéconomique de votre de votre
éducation de la langue que vous parlez
de votre capacité à vous déplacer si
vous accédez ou pas à cette clinique
leur qui est à jack sim donc la capitale
de l'état mais si vous habitez à
500km de jackson il faut avoir un
véhicule il faut pouvoir prendre congé
du travail il faut si vous avez déjà des
enfants il faut s'organiser pour la
garde des enfants donc y'a tellement
d'obstacles qui ont été mises en place
que en fait dans certains états le droit
est pratiquement inopérant pour un des
pour certains groupes de la société et
ça ça découle donc la décision de 1989
et par la suite la cour suprême a eu à
se prononcer en 92 puis en 2016 et
finalement 2020 sur la question
d'avortement et à chaque fois on donner
plus de pouvoir aux états
et ça permettait d' adopter davantage de
ce type de loi le qui vise à la fois les
cliniques et les femmes elles-mêmes dans
les dents les les trois étapes qui
mentionnait de la grossesse la troisième
bascule
l'enfant ou le foetus ou l'enfant
devient un atout pour les taux potentiel
est ce que c'est vraiment cette raison
là où est ce qu'ils imaginent qu'ils
aient vraiment la raison religieuse
aussi derrière ce au niveau de la cour
suprême le texte de rovi waits est
vraiment indiqué c'est l'étape protéger
des intérêts
au niveau de la vie à naître donc c'est
vraiment un texte qui est juridique qui
divise apprécié l'interprétation
unis jouit dans les lois qui sont
adoptées des aspects idéologiques qui
sont liées à la religion mais au niveau
de la décision de la cour suprême
c'était vraiment une distinction entre
les trois étapes et le point c'était
vraiment le point de viabilité donc
mieux puisqu'à ce moment là de la
grossesse si dans une grossesse qui veut
être mené à terme il ya un accouchement
qui est précipitée mais l'enfant peut
vivre à l'extérieur du corps de l'enfant
c'est vraiment plus fort mais j'imagine
que c'est vraiment dans le dans la
législation c'est sûr mais ce qui pousse
les activistes contre le droit à
l'avortement j'imagine qu'il ya beaucoup
de d'idéologie derrière ce jusque plus
que deux comme voici un contribuable
potentiel du oui/non pourrait pour ceux
qui demandent à ce qui est plus de
restrictions dans le deuxième le loup le
premier trimestre voire qu'on abolisse
complètement robert wade et qu'on
revienne à une situation de
criminalisation de l'avortement ce sont
des arguments qui sont ancrées dans
l'idée que la vie commence au moment de
la conception puis des arguments qui
sont liées à certains certaines
religions parce qu'il faut préciser que
toutes les religions qui considèrent que
la vie commence à la conception est donc
l avortement est
malade est le premier des premiers
instants j'avoue que c'est une vision sa
vision que assez
centré sur nos propres croyances le jeu
nous procure ans les croyances
occidentales les plus répandues aux
états unis donc oui la région qui plus
ce protestante évangélique et même le
catholicisme qui que c'est cette vision
là donc de la conception de la vie qui
commence au moment de la conception
mais
ceci me donne et que j'avais pas
utiliser l'état peut décider de
conserver ses intérêts qu'est ce qu'on
voudrait parler dans le fond vraiment
que l'enfant le potentiel enfin il est
perçu comme un futur contribuer à
beaucoup que enfants à partir du moment
où il ya un point de fiabilité ça peut
être considéré comme
ce que la cour suprême vient dire c'est
que l'état a un intérêt à protéger cette
ville parce que on est à porter le c
est donc à partir de ce moment l'on peut
décider que on interdit l'avortement
parce que on a franchi le point de
viabilité donc c'est vraiment le sur cet
enjeu et par la suite en 92 la cour est
revenue sur cette définition l'oeil et
le point de viabilité encore une fois
été réaffirmée donc il ya eu avant
viabilité et le après viabilité et c'est
vraiment un point qui guident qu'est-ce
que les étapes faire en termes de
restrictions au droit à l'avortement on
parlait un peu plus tôt de ceux qui
attendent une époque
avant avoir 113 les avortements
clandestins c'est quelque chose qui
était répandu mais j'imagine que dans
les états où l'avortement est
extrêmement restreint salon encore
exister ça existe encore mais c'est
différent puisque pour ce que lorsqu'on
parle de est ce que rob et wayne va être
renversé ou peut on reviendrait pas une
situation pré robbie oued avec les
cintres et les les conditions plus tard
parce que depuis il ya eu le
développement de ce qu'on appelle et
avortement médicaux donc on fait une
distinction dans le domaine médical
entre les avortements chirurgicaux et
les avortements midi court donc
l'avortement chirurgical c'est dans une
salle d'opération avec des ladies du
tout-petit médicaux et l'avortement
médical c'est en fait deux pilules qui
sont prises un certain intervalle
temporel qui provoque dans le fond un
avortement et cette combinaison la de
médicaments il ya possibilité
aujourd'hui de se la procurer en ligne
il ya un des deux médicaments qui le
misoprostol qui est en vente libre dans
certains pays d'amérique latine
également est juste le misoprostol seul
c'est à peu près 1 85 % d'efficacité
pour mettre un terme à une grossesse la
combinaison avec le mifi mifi prostate
ça amène à presque 95 % d'efficacité
donc vu que c'est cette possibilité là
qui existe aujourd'hui aix est efficace
jusqu'à peu près la 10e semaine
on ne parle pas du même type
d'avortements clandestins mais il ya
certains états que sachant que ceux-ci
existent criminalise les avortements dix
maisons donc si vous tentez de mettre un
terme à une grossesse hors du domaine
médical ça peut être une base sur
laquelle vous pouvez être poursuivi
sachant comment c'est facile de traquer
notre historique sous google ce genre
d'affaires tu prends pas vraiment changé
mais y en a en fait qu'ils prennent et
ce qu'on voit être vraiment intéressant
le new york times avec google on fait
une recherche il ya de cela presque cinq
ans maintenant mais qui est quand même
très intéressante où ils ont regardé la
géographiquement ils ont positionné les
recherches google pour tous les termes
liés à avortement maison comment
provoquer un avortement et autres et ils
ont juste à poser sur une carte avec où
sont les états les plus restrictifs en
matière d'accès à l'avortement et on
voyait que dans les dix états les plus
restrictifs y avait parmi les les dans
les sept 7 des 17 heures où il y avait
le plus de recherches faisaient partie
du top 10 des états les plus restrictifs
sans doute
parce que c'est une méthode qui est qui
qui dangereuses ou qui a des risques il
ya ce l'avortement médical en salle a
été approuvé notamment par le food and
drug administration dans les années 2000
donc s'il ya une procédure à suivre et
c'est également une pratique des
communes dans le bouche à oreille en
amérique latine égal mais aux états unis
ce que c est ce que c'est légal ou
illégal l'avortement médical c'est légal
mais il ya aussi possibilité de se
procurer en ligne donc pour par exemple
l'avortement médical est pas disponible
ou que la femme ne veulent pas passer
par la procédure médicale parce qu'il ya
des femmes qui en fait tout l'aspect
médical entourant l'avortement et
leurs cris de l'inconfort il ya des
sites web qui existent pour commander
ses médicaments là il ya des recherches
qui ont été faites sur 18 sites web
différents ont testé le la colla les
pilules qui recevait et c'est
relativement le fiable comme comme mais
claude rich une
parenthèse mais ce que au québec au
canada c'est quelque chose qui fait les
gars ce qui est légal mais les
avortements médicaux sont que c'est
connu ce que s'est répandue ou que je ne
connaissais pas ça c'est connu par
contre il faut une formation spécifique
pour prescrire l'avortement médical de
mémoire mais là après lé exactement le
tous les éléments que le collège des
médecins au canada demande je prêt peut
vous dire mais
c'est quelque chose qui est illégal
également par contre la période
temporelle pendant laquelle ça peut être
utilisée c'est assez restreint le faut
vraiment utilisé avant la 10e semaine
tandis que les avortements chirurgicaux
peuvent aller au-delà de la dixième
semaine
puis
à 20 d'enfants la cour suprême
je pense que s'ils sont neuf neuf juges
puis est ce que parce que là
dernièrement on a vu le sous
l'administration de rome qui a
inscrit trois nouveaux juges durant son
mandat de quatre ans fait qu' évidemment
des juges plus conservateurs
pendant tout son mandat on se faisait
dire si ça continue ça met en danger le
droit à l'avortement le tout le monde
semblait dire non non non ça se passera
pas de même c'est sait trop si c'est
plus compliqué que ça puis finalement on
se rend compte que
aussitôt que le mans déterminé que les
juges en chef sont à pointer l'ofppt et
qui peuvent plus bouger beloeil à une
loi comme celle là kipa j'imagine que
c'est par hasard il ya eu beaucoup de
lois aussi qui sont passés sous dans
notre chambre puis en fait c'est que
actuellement devant la cour suprême on
commence à avoir des causes qui touchent
des lois qui ont été adoptés pendant le
mandat de notre jeu parce que pour que
l'on arrive devant la cour suprême pour
que ça passe par les autres étapes du
procédé de processus judiciaire aux
etats-unis et ça peut prendre du temps
de prendre deux à trois ans entre le
moment où la loi est adoptée et le
moment où ça se retrouve devant la cour
suprême donc on commence à voir des lois
du début du mandat de donald trump être
entendu mais effectivement le les quatre
ans de dons ne chôme son discours sur
cette question le les discours de mike
pence également le vice président sur
ces questions et les nominations non
seulement la cour suprême mais également
à toutes les autres cours inférieurs
parce que votre eastick dans notre jeu
on peut faire nommer des juges ou 6 ha
dans plusieurs autres cour fédérale a
effectivement donné un souffle au
mouvement anti choix hills et on a vu
vraiment une augmentation marquée du
nombre de lois être adoptée au niveau
des législateurs d'état et des lois
conservatrice va être proposé dans
pratiquement toutes les législatures
d'état le même dans des textes
démocrates ils ont peu été adopté mais
ça donne quand même été proposée est
effectivement là on se questionnait as
que la cour suprême va
voir on verse heroes vi wade il ya eu un
premier cas qui a été entendu par la
cour suprême et dont la décision a été
rendue en juin 2020 si elle ma mémoire
est bonne au niveau de la date qui
concernait une loi de la louisiane qui
était très similaire un loi texane qui a
été renversé par la cour suprême en 2016
robin frijns qui était une autre
décision de la cour suprême et dans
cette décision là on pensait que la cour
allait potentiellement pencher du côté
du mouvement anti choix mais le juge en
chef le juge roberts dit c'est en tout
point similaire à la loi de 2016 quant à
l'audition de 2016 donc on je ne peux
pas dire que c'est une loi qui
constitutionnel parce que ça va contre
le précédent il raconte la décision
qu'on a déjà pris exactement sauf que le
jeu jouable tu n'es pas nommé par ne pas
été nommé par de notre chambre et les
trois juges qui ont été nommés pas dans
mon job ont voté pour maintenir la loi
de la louisiane le prochain test ce
n'est ps dès 8 que dont le hub un
certain écho de la cour suprême au début
septembre mais le 1er décembre c'est une
carte une date à marquer au calendrier
parce que on commencera à entendre les
arguments oraux dans un cas qui touche
une loi du mississippi adopté en 2018
qui resterait l'avortement delà de la
15e semaine d'auxi on se rappelle le
cadre de robbie oued premier trimestre
deuxième trimestre troisième trimestre
15 semaines c'est au tout début du
deuxième trimestre à un moment où
techniquement un état ne peut pas
interdire l'accès à l'avortement c'est
vraiment lent contestation direct du
coeur de robbie wade est ce que la cour
suprême va décider dans la kozah être
entendue donc du mississippi peut donner
pour nous indiquer le sirop vie wade
sera renversé ont donc
ce qui s'est passé début septembre
c'est pas que robbie oued été renversé
mais comment est-ce que en fait
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce que
ça le pas
je veux comprendre ce point là parce que
si le 1er décembre c'est la première
vraie cause qui pourrait renverser le
héros vie moyenne en fait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé début septembre exauce donc
le 1er septembre au matin donc à minuit
entre le 31 août et le 1er septembre une
loi qui rentre et en vigueur au texas et
une loi qui a été adopté en mai dernier
donc été si par le gouverneur de l'état
ça fait déjà quelques mois qu'on savait
que si elle était pas bloquer salal
entre en vigueur et c'est la loi qu'on
appelle s v8 donc en fait la loi texane
sa prévoit deux choses sales interdit
l'accès à l'avortement à partir du
moment où une contraction foetale peut
être entendue donc ce que les les anti
choix appelle un battement de coeur mais
que c'est ce n'est pas un battement de
coeur parce que le cas on n'est pas
encore formé donc mais qui a une
activité des tissus fait tôt
et de l'autre côté fatigué en fait cette
loi là contrairement aux autres lois de
rugby bill qu'on a entendues dans les
dernières années a adopté dans d'autres
états ce n'est pas l'état de l'exode qui
va être responsable de s'assurer de sa
mise en oeuvre ça va être les citoyens
privés donc n'importe qui à travers le
pays peut poursuivre quelqu'un qui a
aidé ou eu l'intention d'aider une femme
au texas à obtenir un avortement au delà
de la sixième semaine et ça pose une
question juridique est vraiment
particulière parce qu'on peut pas
poursuivre l'état du texas pour dire la
loi vous avez adopté et non
constitutionnel parce que c'est pas eux
qui vont l'appliquer la loi dont ils
peuvent de belles
la loi ou non ne l'appliquent peut donc
en fait c'est les citoyens privés qui
sont responsables de ça et c'est sur ce
point là que la cour suprême en fait
après 23 heures de silence suite à
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi a dit on
ne se prononce pas sur est-ce que c'est
constitutionnel ou pas donc est-ce que
ça respecte trop vives ou peu mais ce
qu'on dit c'est que ça pose des
questions qui sont plus complexe que ça
et donc on la laisse en vigueur mais ça
n'empêche pas de contestation par la
suite sur le point de la
constitutionnalité mais c'est ça dans le
fond parce que il ya comme pas il ya
comme personne à poursuivre par rapport
à
rien à faire le petit temps qui avait
pas une paix un citoyen privé qui
poursuivait une clinique où un médecin
ou n'importe quel un chauffeur de
livres tous brute taxi peu importe et il
n'y avait pas de cause directe sur
laquelle on pouvait contester la loi il
ya eu par contre le gouvernement fédéral
qui a annoncé qu'il poursuivait le
gouvernement du texas donc pour
l'application de cette loi le pas sur la
base de rovi oued uniquement mais sur la
base du partage des pouvoirs fédéral
fédérer et sur la clause de la supprime
ainsi donc on a utilisé une autre voie
d'entrée et afin de permettre ces
poursuites judiciaires là il ya
également un médecin du texas qui
procéder à un avortement au delà de la
sixième semaine c'est septembre et qui a
écrit un article dans le washington post
qui a dit je suis médecin au texas et
j'ai réalisé un avortement au texas pour
cela me semble poursuivre et meurant et
salaires fonctionner parce qu'il ya deux
poursuites actuellement contre c médecin
la messe à la échoué également du côté
des anti choix parce que ces deux
poursuites là ne sont pas par des
militants anti choix c'est par un
militant pro choix de l'illinois qui a
dit moi je suis pro choix mais il faut
que cette loi leur ca est donc il faut
convoquer une poursuite en
cour suprême se prononce sur ce col 1
mais pour que dans le feuillet un
précédent sur lequel on peut se pencher
très bien ça le peu de bon sens pour
dire que c'est andy constitution
exactement voilà et l'autre personne
c'est un ancien avocat de l'arkansas qui
a dit moi je poursuis papa par rapport
au débat pro choix ou anti choix mais
parce que la loi doit être respectée
donc vu que c'est la loi puisqu'il l'a
pas respectée je le poursuis donc c'est
mais c'est donc pas une simple ses caves
sinon mais il me semble que c'est qu'on
s'y
pourquoi je comprends juste pas pourquoi
il a fallu que ça passe pour ce par là
pourquoi y'a personne qui est une
juridiction complète pourquoi il n'y a
pas de c'est juste la nature de la
politique américaine c'est la façon de
la loi a été écrite tel objectif en fait
t'es ces lois là sont pas prises au
hasard puis s'inscrit vraiment dans des
années d'activisme législatif par des
groupes qui parfois ne se compris il se
concentre uniquement sur ceux dont il ya
des groupes qui existe aux états unis
que leur travail ils écrivent des lois
des projets de loi et ensuite ils vont
magasiner auprès des législateurs leur
disais j'ai écrit une loi sur ce site où
veux tu as juste à mettre ton nom le nom
de ton et à la date puis bing deals où
sont rédigées par des militants anti
choix faits en eux que c'est de cette
façon là mais aussi des lèche la parc
son antre choix qui doit aider les
autres qui ont vu le look rose et en
fait on rentrait dans ce look selon paul
lapie on verra ce qui se passe après
exact juste pour
briser le statu quo un peu oui med ils y
ont aussi réussi d'une certaine façon
parce qu'actuellement au texas outre ce
médecin dont qui a ouvertement défié la
loi les cliniques se conforme à la loi
et donc actuellement au texas il n'y a
pas d'avortement au delà de la sixième
semaine et ses 85 % des patients autres
qui sont touchés par ce parce qu'une 85%
les avortements exerce se produisent
après la sixième semaine donc d'un côté
ion utilisées oui un loupé rôle mais ils
sont arrivés à leurs fins à un certain
niveau dans le dernier mois donc en
attendant notons que
parce que le clairement ces lois là il
passe en 2018 puis que les lions le
moment d'en parler maintenant on
s'entend que si c'est des procédures qui
sont lentes et l'ongle fait qu'en ce
moment mais ton il ya des femmes qui ont
pas accès à l'avortement qui vont
potentiellement peut-être y avoir accès
il faut que ça va être réglé décidé en
cour suprême et que pour l'instant il ya
plus d'avortements qui seront exaucés la
loi actuelle elle était passée en mai
2021 puis appliquez en septembre et à
travers le processus judiciaire est
possible il ya possibilité pour les gens
qui demandent l'arrêt de cette loi le
d'avoir un sursis pendant lequel s'est
pas appliqué donc pendant le temps qui
ont les procédures judiciaires dans le
fond on peut demander à ce que la loi ne
s'applique pas et c'est le cas au
mississippi actuellement et des
avortements delà de la 15e semaine parce
que pendant le procès dure la processus
judiciaire on dit ben on n'applique pas
la loi jusqu'à ce qu'on établisse cissé
constitutionnel ou peut donc ça c'est
une des étapes et l'administration paris
xii notamment demandé à ce que la loi
soit suspendue au texas et l'audience
est dans les jours à venir donc la
première audience à ce niveau là le 1er
octobre
qui transforme un don qu'elle est le
juge en première instance au niveau de
la cour de district a pressé la décision
peut être porté en appel au niveau de la
cour fédérale et ensuite ça va la course
prime mêle donc il faut déjà passer pour
la bloquer le projet de loi la cour
suprême fait qu'elle a fait c'est elle a
émis un avis parce qu'on appelle le
shadow dos quitte donc on a dit on en
entend pas de ya pas eu d' arguments
oraux il paye d'arguments écrit il ya
peu eu de processus judiciaire en fait
on a fait appel à la cour suprême en
urgence et on a dit s'il vous plaît
bloquer la loi parce que bosser c'est
contraire au droit aux états unis et la
cour suprême décide et sans audience ni
rien d'émettre un avis qui dit nous
n'empêcherons pas l'application de la
loi mais les avis aurait pu être
contraires et dire on empêche
l'application de la loi messi n'est pas
un processus judiciaire devant la cour
suprême que c'est vraiment un avis en
urgence qui a été demandée ce niveau là
puisque
qu est-ce qu est-ce qu on peut envisager
qui qui qui va se passer est ce que tu
penses que ça va remonter jusqu'à la
cour suprême ou qui est ce que où est ce
que la loi va juste rester en vigueur on
va se plier aux critiques et de remonter
jusqu'à la cour suprême parce qu en fait
peu importe qui remporte qui gagne en
première instance l'autre partie veut
contester on va aller en cour fédérale
d'appel peu importe qui remporte en cour
fédérale d'appel on va aller à la cour
suprême donc très sûrement d'un côté
comme de l'autre on risque de se rendre
jusqu'à la cour suprême et
également pour répondre c'est à l'autre
partie de ta question que plutôt sur le
les conséquences directes sur les femmes
si la loi ne peut même si la loi est
suspendu en fait il ya des cliniques qui
ferme à cause de cette loi là
actuellement et si on se rapporte à la
loi de 2012 qui avait été adoptée puis
par la suite invalidée par la cour
suprême dans la portion où elle a été
appliquée saleh mené à la fermeture de
50% des cliniques de l'état du texas et
très peu ont réouvert depuis
actuellement territoire ciat 24 clinique
c'est énorme et exhorté avant 2012 on
était au dessus de 40 cliniques donc les
impacts peuvent être déjà ressemble ci
étant sur les femmes qui sont les
cliniques peuvent même si la cour
suprême dit que la loi est non
constitutionnelle puis que son
application est enlevée ça veut pas dire
que l'accessibilité va redevenir ce
qu'elle était avant l'effet
exactement qui gisait qu' il y avait
d'autres états conservateurs qui
pensaient emboîté le pas avec cette
couleuvre voyant que ça peut fonctionner
mener à
des changements même si éventuellement
c'est pour y retourner de bord au bout
de la ligne j'en parlais de la floride
qui pensaient peut-être pour sûr c'est
qu'en est il de ce oui et certains états
les dakota du sud a annoncé qu'ils
voulaient explorer l'idée également
l'arkansas qui voisin du texas ou si
vous voulez explorer l'idée au niveau de
la floride
gouvernants le lecteur en 210 changé son
fusil d'épaulé en fait à la suite des
premières discussions sur cet enjeu là
parce que la stratégie en fait est salué
par une portion du mouvement choix mais
il y en a aussi qui s'opposent à cette
stratégie-là de rendre les citoyens
privés responsables d'appliquer une loi
et si l'argument que one de synthèse
utilisée en disant moi je ne signerai
pas loi ou si les citoyens privés qui
sont responsables de l'application parce
que le l'autre côté de cette méthode là
c'est que si on se met à utiliser cette
méthode le beh oui les états
conservateurs peuvent l'utiliser sur des
enjeux comme l'avortement mais après les
étapes progressives pourrait très bien
l'utiliser sur des enjeux liés aux
communautés génétique plus aller au port
d'armes à moi ceci son voisin tu peux tu
peux poursuivre ton voisin pour avoir
des armes dans son garage le voilà
tout le monde peut utiliser liberté des
activistes de gauche qui vont arriver
avec ceux
ayant naquit c'est qu'ils sont plus
refroidis à l'utilisation de cette
méthode là parce que si tu commences à
utiliser c'est ben en fait c'est pas
juste on comptait qui peut l'utiliser
c'est l'autre côté du débat aussi qu'ils
peuvent l'utiliser le pire admettons moi
je t'ai citoyens texan conservateurs
républicains je suis un serveur teum en
biologie vaincu
7 mois le g20
ma voisine
s'est fait avorter fait que je décide de
poursuivre la clinique ou poursuivre
n'importe qui qui l'a aidé à présent que
je poursuis art mon nom c'est moi qui
entoure l'île témoin qui qui assure les
frais d'avocat les frais tout sur le
tchèque mais quel citoyen va vraiment sa
barque à l'aise dans ces procédures le
pour tous les savoisiens nous tiens
la loi en fait on pensait à cette
question là et ce qui se passe c'est que
si la poursuite
en fait si la cour donne raison la
personne qui poursuit la clinique doc
sélectivement n'y a pas de prouver que
la clinique effectivement effectué un
avortement que la sixième semaine de
la personne qui est poursuivi doivent
payer un minimum de dix mille dollars en
primes et tous vos frais d'avocat par
contre à linverse si vous poursuivez
quelqu'un et que la personne est jugée
non coupable
vous n'avez pas à payer les frais
d'avocats de la clinique du médecin du
chauffeur de taxi peu importe qui vous
poursuivez et où c'est un bémol
important tout le monde qui a aidé la
femme qui contribuent qui participent à
l'avortement peut être poursuivi mais la
patiente elle même ne peut pas être
poursuivi que donc c'est quand même un
peu point important ce n'est pas ce que
quelques années il y avait des lois qui
était proposée autre exemple que la
personne qui était
criminaliser c'était vraiment la
patiente mais là c'est tout le monde qui
est autour de la place en finale baugé
en ce moment se perd la loi de pod
poursuivi fera exactement parce que si
les coûts énormes en termes juridiques
le qui peuvent qui peuvent être
occasionnée est actuellement les
cliniques au texas en fait tourner leur
faune et leur flore temps et tous vers
l'aide aux patientes pour les aider en
fait à sortir du texas pour accéder aux
soins dans les états limitrophes hockey
ou l'accepter
mais
si on veut parce que ça dépend si vous
êtes au texas si vous êtes proche
d'affronter avec le nouveau mexique
absolument le nouveau-mexique des lois
beaucoup plus permissive que les
exercent de façon générale sur l'accès à
l'avortement par contre aller en
oklahoma aller en arc ensoa la louisiane
c'est plus
difficile parce qu'ils y ont eux mêmes
des lois restrictives en matière
d'avortement c'est possible d'avoir un
avortement de la sixième semaine donc
c'est plus facile côté xi mais il ya
quand même le des restrictions et à ce
niveau là les il ya des cliniques qui
ont dit qu'ils ont déjà sorti des
chiffres par rapport à nombre de femmes
texane qui viennent et on voit vraiment
que dans l'oklahoma qui est un peu moins
pire que les autres sur cette question
leur a vraiment reçu le une très grande
peur des patientes texane avec le
nouveau mexique alors que leur kansas
puis la louisiane mont houy connu une
augmentation de l'achalandage des
cliniques par b texane mais pas autant
que les autres états est je pense une
clinique en oklahoma à oklahoma city que
maintenant ça dans son bassin de
patientes le deux tiers ce sont des
texans et le tiers ce sont des femmes de
l'oklahoma alors qu'en louisiane vont y
passer de 2 % à 19 % des patients
provenant du texas quand même si ces
fous qui est ce que cette
tendance le
semble vouloir prendre
le
lantus choix le moment du choix le tiki
ça fait longtemps qu'ils que ça existe
c'est ce qu'on est ce qu on sent qu'il
ya une tendance
va vers la hausse ce mouvement-là aux
états unis en ce moment lorsqu'on
regarde les sondages en fait qu'on voit
c'est que les positionnements de la
société américaine est quand même assez
stable depuis robbi weldon calliope qui
est une firme de sondage qui à chaque
année sont les américains sur plusieurs
enjeux et qui à chaque année pose la
même question sur l'accès à l'avortement
est ce que vous êtes en faveur du
maintien de rovi oued oui ou non et une
majorité d'américains constamment
demeure en faveur du maintien de rovi
wade par contre là où ça divergent et
qu' une augmentation d'un certain niveau
de restriction c'est lorsqu'on demande
la question est ce que vous êtes en
faveur de l'avortement dans n'importe
quelle circonstance dans certaines
circonstances ou jamais et l'on voit que
la majorité c'est dans certaines
circonstances qu'il se trouve donc on
mais encore là c'est que c'est tellement
vaste certaines circonstances quelqu'un
qui s'oppose par exemple à l'avortement
au delà du point de viabilité rentrerez
dans certaines circonstances donc c'est
assez vaste mais on voit que il y à
vraiment instabilité dans le
positionnement des américains qui sont
son départ galope de 1973 à aujourd'hui
le les variations c'est comme un ou deux
pourcent
c'est vraiment par rapport à d'autres
enjeux sociaux sur lesquels il vraiment
le démonter de soutien ou des baisses
importantes de soutien mais au niveau
législatif mettons depuis 113 on parle
absolument et c'est là la différence en
fait c'est lorsqu'on regarde dans
l'opinion publique donc l'américain
moyen ce qu'ils pensent du droit à
l'avortement versus ce qu'on pourrait
avoir comme idée de ckoi l'opinion
publique en regardant juste les
législateurs c'est complètement
différent ces deux mondes et ça ça fait
partie de la stratégie du mouvement de
choix de se concentrer sur les
législatures détail de faire élire des
législateurs anti choix donc lorsqu'on
regarde la composition par exemple de
l'assemblée législative au texas on a
l'impression que 75% des texans sont
contre le droit à l'avortement alors que
lorsqu'on regarde les sondages de
l'opinion publique au texas s'est pas
seulement la réalité mais les autres
forces politiques notamment le dj
remembering
l'accessibilité du vote les les gens qui
ont les moyens financiers de se
présenter également mais ça fait en
sorte qu'on ait un décalage complet
entre la représentation politique puis
l'opinion puis les minorités la minorité
finalement en choix librement
premièrement un militantisme plus
fervents et passionné que la majorité
qui sont proches ou amis quand fonds
poële à la bataille de leur vie parfait
c'est ce qui est difficile c'est que
quand il ya une cause qui est à gagner
c'est beaucoup plus facile de rallier
des gens c'est à dire que si il n'y
avait pas de droit à l'avortement ce
serait plus facile de rallier des gens
qui d'ailleurs il faut se battre pour ce
droit là merci ce qu'on a un droit qui
est là depuis longtemps il ya des jeunes
générations que jamais connu les
etats-unis sans accès à l'avortement est
donc de dire ça pourrait ne plus être le
effacer d'ici la conceptualité c'est
plus du secondaire et je vais me battre
pour ce moins urgents comme combo 6 e
versus de dire bex elop il faut que ça
disparaisse qu'il faut qu'on s'y
attellent maintenant donc le pouvoir
d'attraction peu difficile et c'est un
des éléments qui est soulevée par les
groupes pro choisi lorsqu'il ya des
causes par exemple la loi sb tout existe
par exemple des décisions de judiciaire
mais il ya une augmentation des dons à
ces organismes là et dès que la décision
est rendue ou un mois ou deux après la
loi veil one chute dans les dents les
cotisations dans l'élite l'aide
financière la ces organisations là parce
que c'est un droit qui existe
actuellement dans ces difficiles de
khalid dire ça existe qu il faut se
battre pour ce donc c'est pas une
capacité d'organisation qui est
différente de par ce décalage le il ya
aussi que le mouvement tu as été très
actif sur le plan législatif au niveau
des états fédérés
et on commence à voir cet activisme
l'eau du côté des actrices activistes
pro choix donc parallèlement aux états
conservateurs qui adoptent des
restrictions et des étapes progressives
qui adoptent des protections au droit à
l'avortement donc on voit des états qui
ont chassé droit là dans leur
constitution qui adoptent des lois
positives pour assurer que si robbie
wattignies à tomber l'avortement demeure
est légal dans l'or dans leurs états
puis
le sbbl à la loi sb huit ans qu'elle va
être
rendue
selon ce que tu dis on va se rendre
jusqu'en cour suprême
parce qu'il est ce que la balance
[Musique]
54 conservateur de deux juges
conservateurs à la cour suprême
qui ça regarde comment ce parce que ça
regarde moyen de
180 parce que comme je l'entends ça
regarde quand même moyen parce que je me
rappelle quand c'était la
justice
ruth ginsburg qui quand elle est décédée
qui l'ont remplacé par jeu c'est quoi le
nom de la wes exacte et que l'on
remplacé par s
je me rappelle que c'était assez mitigé
comme comme réception elle est arrivée
avec un discours assez neutre asin calme
posé sauf que derrière on entendait un
petit peu les gens plus libéraux dire
dire que c'était problématique quand
même sur ces questions là les quelques
trucs croyant je pense qu'il ya 10 à 1,3
me décision mettait des convictions et
des convictions c'est ce fait que ça se
rende la maintenance n'a fermé une fois
rendu le il ya quand même des chances
que ça parle 54 pour pour le maintien de
la loi exactement et à ce niveau là ce
qui va être important de regarder c'est
que il ya oui le spectre idéologique
sont venus sur lequel les juges se
situent donc plus conservatoires être
plus progressistes mais dans la question
juridique et comme un autre niveau qui
est
l'importance de la tradition donc est ce
qu on considère que la constitution des
états unis elle est vivante donc on doit
l'interpréter selon les peuples dans
laquelle on se trouve ou est ce qu'elle
doit être interprétée comme les pères
fondateurs l'on écrit au moment de la
rédaction
dans les années 1700
réponses
posées
des jurys se situe sur la constitution a
été écrite par les pères fondateurs
ainsi la constitution n'a pas été
modifié depuis son écriture elle doit
donc être interprétées telle qu'elle a
été pensée par les pères fondateurs
donc il ya cette tradition-là qui
expliquent le conservatisme versus le
progressisme pour pas utiliser les mêmes
termes que le politique parce qu'on est
vraiment dans le juridique et l'autre
élément qui est important à souligner
c'est le respect de la tradition
donc est-ce qu'on a des juges pour qui
le précédent c'est important où les
précédents peuvent être modifiées et à
ce niveau là c'est là que ça va être
intéressant de près du juridique la
question de rovi wade parce que selon
les juges destitués pourrait décider de
ne pas de renverser en fait la loi est
de 8 sur la base que robbie oued c'est
le précédent et le précédent doit
demeurer donc on est lié par le
précédent et c'est l'argument qu'il juge
roberts un l'évoquer en 2020 lorsqu'il a
dit
moi je voterai pas nécessairement si
aujourd'hui avait juste cette loi là je
vois très content mais je suis lié par
le précédent je n'ai pas le choix de
voter de cette façon là il était comme
ceux qui le pressent présenté dans
l'explication de sa décision donc est-ce
que s'il est confronté à un potentiel
renversement de robin wood il faut dire
je suis lié par le précédent et je dois
respecter robbie wade ou pas des là où
le juge roberts pourrait être le vote
qui pourrait pencher d'un côté de
l'autre parce que les quatre autres
juges
plus conservateurs
sont pour le renversement de rovi web de
façon plus globale et les quatre jeux
plus progressistes sont en faveur de son
maintien et l'autre question en suspens
si c'est que il ya le juge boureux qui
est plus
assuré que maraval ici pas impossible
lui plus de gueule borne donc lui et
progressiste est ok ça se pourrait que
sibide n'est plus au pouvoir et que
c'est un président républicain
donc c'est pour ça que dans les
dernières semaines il ya eu des
pressions pour qu'il prenne sa retraite
ce qui refuse de faire pour ne pas être
influencé par les politiques mais donc
cet aspect là aussi à considérer que au
moment où dans un angle de la loi
pourrait devant la cour suprême être
qu'on va avoir la même composition de la
cour suprême qu'on a en ce moment où est
ce que la composition voix différente de
par des retraites de par des décès ou
jeu c'est fou
repose sur des individus des individus
d'une espèce de conseil suprême c'est
vrai c'est cette
news
4les com com net bisbal sur une
constitution de cette
pression au niveau du congrès d'agir
puis de codifier au viread en loi en
fait pour peu que ce soit uniquement le
pouvoir de neuf personnes de décider si
ses mains nues ou peu et à ce niveau là
donc la chambre des représentants s'est
penché dans la dernière semaine sur un
une loi qui codifie ray les droits en
santé reproductive pour les femmes la
chambre le passé une faible majorité
démocrate à la chambre des représentants
actuellement mais pour que ça passe le
sénat il faut 60 votes donc disent
républicains les chances que ça passe
disons extrêmement mince il ya un
démocrate un sénateur démocrate qui est
contre le droit à l'avortement il ya
deux sénatrices
3 sénatrice républicaine qui sont en
faveur du droit à l'avortement donc
c'était un peu ça augure pas bien contre
la codification le 2 du mois s'écoulent
le pouvoir du président joe biden sur
ces questions de ce qui lui peut
dire c'est très utile il dit des lois
fédérales qui peuvent ouvrir à et
apparaître puis il pourra vendre loi
fédérale c'est ça en fait que la chambre
des représentants et le sénat au niveau
du parti démocrate tenter de faire
adopter mais joe biden peut pas
unilatéralement adopter des lois le
pouvoir est au congrès et la majorité du
démocrate aux démocrates au sénat est
trop mince pour un couple parfait un
projet de loi qui est aussi chargé
politiquement que le droit à
l'avortement actuellement parce que
c'est très très polarisée comme droite
se divise vraiment le sur les lignes de
parti au niveau des cellules comme
gérant des trois républicaines qui sont
en faveur du droit à l'avortement il ya
un démocrate qui est contre le cvu
vraiment sur les lignes de partage
en direct
on dirait que ça regarde pas bien dans
le bon le tipi
j'ai l'impression que
la pente est glissante à partir de là
parce que si ça passe de ce côté là
puisque l'aca se rend en cour suprême
puisqu'elle s'est confirmé que
finalement on renverse euro vi wade qui
à nous piquer le way c'est ce qui est un
niveau précédente que le les autres
états emboîte le pas pour les états unis
ce dangereux mais
moins que lors des dernières élections
fédérales ici au canada où est ce qu'il
y avait des
ministres des ministres et des députés
conservateurs qui disait à être anti
choix je trouve ça devient dangereux
pour même ici le droit à l'avortement ou
un pied en fait durant la campagne
électorale et reno tour le chef
conservateur avait eu une question leur
mais les prêts sont lui demander s'il ya
un an passant justement tu exerces en
fait si une province qui décident de
restreint le droit à l'avortement est ce
que vous allez à g et il a répondu non
je n'en dirai pas si les provinces
agissent de façon unilatérale et après
le 20 septembre les sélections son sens
au mot son ils n'ont pas passé mais
c'est quand même un discours qui y est
quitte à garder en tête pour la ces des
choses le parti conservateur ne va pas
nulle part je voyais des élus est
encore le deuxième parti qui a une bonne
chance de prendre s'y
personnellement je pense un avortement
où il a voulu enlever la question de
l voilà donc il n'y a pas c'est un des
seuls moments le oui touché à la
question du droit à l'avortement pluie
personnellement mais ces députés il ya
des députés anti choix dans le caucus
conservateur et à chaque année ou
presque les députés anti choix du code
de conservateurs proposent des lois qui
visent à restreindre le droit à
l'avortement au canada également mais
même au delà du canada en fête qui est
les etats unis qui sont quand même une
puissance mondiale
et qui ont un poids
symbolique également long terme de
diffusion de la culture et autres que
une restriction de ce droit à
l'avortement le qui soit aussi flagrante
ça peut avoir des impacts aussi sur
d'autres
états sur d'autres
situations à l'international il faut
préciser selon les chiffres du
guttmacher institute
depuis les années depuis le début de
l'année 2000 il ya uniquement trois
états à l'international qui ont
restreint de façon vraiment visible
droit à l'avortement etc le nicaragua la
pologne et les états unis alors que dans
d'autres contextes une libération du
droit à l'avortement ou l'élargissement
de ce droit le même dans des contextes
où la religion est très présente à
quelques jours après l'entrée en vigueur
des sb tout exauce la cour suprême du
mexique a dit que les états n'ont pas le
droit de criminaliser l'avortement au
mexique donc est alors que la la
l'église catholique est particulièrement
importante dans au mexique et c'est à
dire après la décriminalisation
argentine également dans qu'hier il ya
ces deux mouvements là mais le fait que
les états unis restreindre le droit ça
va quand même un pouvoir symbolique qui
est
en fait c'est la prochaine question que
je devais me posez c'est est où est ce
que les unissent se situe par rapport
aux autres cette question le alternant
chansons on avait payé une femme mais au
niveau de l'implantation de restrictions
on voi qui est vraiment un activisme en
termes de restrictions mais l'avortement
pour jusqu'à preuve du contraire au
vivat il existe encore il ya encore une
accessibilité au droit à l'avortement
donc on y est on se situe quand même là
dans le
l'appel le groupe des états qui
reconnaissent le droit à l'avortement
actuellement alors qu'il ya d'autres
états où il n'y a absolument pas de
droit à l'avortement et donc il n'y a
pas de possibilité de le restreindre
parce qu'ils n'existaient pas steve lee
trois étapes j'ai nommé c'est qu'il y
avait des volonté de restreindre le
droit la force du trou de douai ce que
la situation
s'empire en guinée exactement voilà et
de l'autre côté là où ça s'améliore
aussi mais ça peut ça peut jouer aussi
le sourcing mouvement leur qui ont pris
des années à établir pour améliorer la
situation ailleurs si on a les
etats-unis qui font d autant d peu de
recul s'est
constamment à a regagné en fait c'est
comme jamais une question qui règle un
autre et ça revient tout le temps sur la
tapis justement finalement
ne tombe mettons c'est pas impossible
qu'au canada sont un gouvernement
conservateur sachant qu'il ya des anti
choix
impossible pour un mac soit élu parce
que semble pas aussi longtemps que
possible les favoris lité au début de la
campagne des favoris ça se pourrait
qu'au canada ce quelque chose qu'on voit
des con con con abbott le poste du
snuipp qu'on est de plus en plus de
réactions c'est quelque chose qui se
perd oui et puis même même sans les
restrictions en fait j'ai un peu plus
tôt se tenir au viread vitter
l'aplanissement des disparités
géographiques mais avec toutes les haies
les restrictions qui ont été mises en
place dans 30 des 50 était en fait on
voit un retour de cette situation là où
l'accès à l'avortement c'est vraiment
une question géographique selon où vous
vous situez sur le territoire mais en
fait vous avez un droit qui est
différent si et c'est quelque chose
qu'on voit au canada aussi donc les
cliniques d'avortement montréal oui on
peut faire une recherche rapide et en
trouver mais si vous habitez nord du
québec la plus proche mais il faut vous
allez jusqu'à vendredi date et dans les
provinces maritimes souvent une ou deux
cliniques pour servir la province au
complet donc on a déjà des situations où
il ya une disparité géographique même si
on n'a pas des restrictions qui
s'apparente aux restrictions aux états
unis par exemple du temps d'attentes un
premier puis un deuxième rendez-vous des
cliniques qui doivent se plier à des
stands or le plus élevé qu'un bloc
opératoire ou presque et donc même si on
ne peut ce type de restriction l'oeil à
caen même des obstacle à l'accessibilité
au canada deux mois s'avère un alberto
c'est une très bonne question je peut se
parler longuement de les 50 états unis
mais je la station albertaine pour
le texte une étape se connaît très bien
ses cliques et puis toi même tes top de
la bo pieds tu y vois souvent j'imagine
où tu es tu as envie de jouer avec oui
mais tu me disais dans le fond que titre
tout soit une conversation avec les
différents labos des gens labo puis qui
a une chance changement de ton depuis
les événements de début septembre le tir
oui absolument d'un café manger mènent
actuellement les entretiens pour ma
thèse lui j'ai commencé à les réaliser
au début du mois d'août donc un mois
avant l'entrée en vigueur des sb vite et
ça continue le durant tout l'automne
donc j'ai eu des entretiens avec des
femmes avant sb huit filles avaient
encore espoir que pour la cour suprême
me bloquer l'application parce que c'est
non constitutionnelles et tout est à
créer ce but et il ya vraiment un
changement dans la perception de
l'accessibilité à l'avortement dans la
gravité que ça va que une grossesse non
planifiée
en termes les motifs puis en termes de
qu'est ce qu'on fait en fait avec ça
parce que avant le 31 où il y avait une
accessibilité aux à l'avortement et le
1er septembre n'avait plus fait et ce
qui ressort beaucoup c'est que sb 8 si
vous êtes une femme avec des moyens
financiers moyennement stable que vous
avez envie que vous pouvez vous déplacer
vous pouvez alors qu'oklahoma vous
pouvez aller au nouveau mexique mais les
les femmes afro américaine
latino-américaine les migrants non
documentées les personnes qui ont des
revenus plus faibles sont directement
touchés par la loi et en fait il n'y a
pas d'autre choix de se déplacer à l
extérieur du texas ce n'est pas une
option et six semaines c'est très très
peu de retour dans démonstration
si rare en fait confié avoir cette
semaine il faut vraiment que tu sois
très très attentif le [ __ ] cycle
bourg pour le savons donc si c'est le
cas par an avec des femmes là-bas il ya
beaucoup de peur il ya beaucoup
d'anxiété à la possibilité d'être
enceinte et la problématique aussi c'est
qu'il ya peu juste des restrictions au
droit à l'avortement exauce mais aussi
des difficultés d'accessibilité à la
contraception donc il ya des pharmacies
qui refuse d'avoir le plan b qui est la
contraception d'urgence donc si jamais
il ya un problème avec la contraception
première pour des raisons idéologiques
parce qu'ils considèrent que c'est une
pilule d'avortement donc il ya eu un
manque d'accessibilité de plan b il ya
des endroits où il ya des manques
d'accessibilité de certains types de
contraception donc les femmes pour
forcer soin de prendre une contraception
qui n'est pas idéal pour eux ou de ne
pas avoir de contraception donc si
toutes ces angelots en fait c'est pas
juste la loi et ce but et c'est injuste
l'accessibilité à la clinique ou peu
mais si cette loi levier dans un
contexte où elle exerce il ya déjà
beaucoup d' entrave à tout ce qui est
droits reproductifs et qui a vraiment
une disparité selon le profil socio
économique d'une femme selon son origine
ethnoculturelle salon ouest qu'elle se
situe dans les domaines
mais ça
j'imagine que ça c'est de creuser encore
plus lésés corps
les accords de
canalisations économique les gens oui
parce qu'entre le marginaliser encore
plus les
migraines à fond qui les personnes de
couleur et les personnes qui ont pas
accès à ces choses là les lits sera plus
pauvres oui parce qu'on forme vraiment
en fait des femmes à devenir mère ou à
avoir un enfant de plus parce qu'il y en
a qui est qu'ils veulent à l'avortement
parce qu'ils ont déjà des enfants que la
contraception ne peuvent fonctionner
lille et autant de raisons d'avoir
d'avortement qu'il ya des femmes mais y
on est dans une situation où donc on
limitation de l'accès à la contraception
pratiquement plus d'accès à l'avortement
mais de l'autre côté il n'y a pas de
programmes sociaux et de filet social
pour les parents le riez pas de garderie
subventionnée il n'y a pas de congé
parental il n'y a pas de hockey on se
retrouve dans une situation où on ne
peut pas mettre un terme à une grossesse
on la difficulté à prévenir les
grossesses puis lorsqu'on on a une
grosse est quand même la grosse s
habiller mes dépendances
exactement donc on n'a pas de concept
qui s'appelle la justice reproductrices
qui est le droit d'avoir de ne pas avoir
d'enfants le droit d'avoir des enfants
le droit de ne pas en avoir ou les
droits de parenté les enfants contes et
en fait on se retrouve dans une
situation exacte on n'a aucune de ces
choix le don peut pas rentrer les
enfants pour nous parce qu'on ne peut
depuis un petit soutien et petit filet
social lily cole coûte extrêmement cher
on ne peut demander un accès limité à la
contraception dans le puits d'accès à
l'avortement
le la solution
demeure l'abstinence là on dit bravo
non mais c'est ça justement c'est ça
c'est tellement que moi personnellement
je serais tellement
nerveux que tu prends pas de chance mais
l'éducation sexuelle n'existe pas non
plus le joueur soit parle d'éducation
sexuelle c'est l'abstinence avant le
mariage puis après le chb en fait c'est
un devoir de se reproduire ici c'est là
où ça rejoint plutôt parler d'eux est ce
que c'est un enjeu qui est idéologique
ou religieux mais oui à un certain
niveau parce que c'est une conception de
de la vie et de la les relations
interpersonnelles et de l'amour qui qui
s'inscrit dans ça et qui a un impact sur
tous les aspects de la santé
reproductive également et on peut même
ajouter une autre couche à ça ou la
question de la reproduction c'est
également par rapport à ça peut être
liés aux enjeux démographiques puis à la
perte d'importance des communautés
blanches aux états unis donc il est tout
aussi ce discours là il peut être lié
avec la volonté de restreint l'accès à
l'avortement depuis tantôt je réfléchis
à la star qui était dit en fait que
depuis
73 l'opinion publique par rapport à
l'avortement pas réellement changé c'est
pis une goutte interdit ce jeudi à pau
ce pays mais en même temps qu'un qu'on
considère aussi que ça s'est fait ces
terribles finalement ratifié que
quiconque constat comme et à progresser
et puis quand est-ce comme étant le
chemin qu'on veut prendre finalement on
ne peut pas avancer du tout en cinquante
ans passés à l'armement mais en fait
c'est qu'il ya une majorité des
électeurs qui soutiennent rovi wade donc
ceci bonne chose que ça allait pas
augmenté il ya toujours une franche qui
veut pas soutenir le droit à
l'avortement pied toujours dans un
contexte où il est on est dans une
société où il ya quand même une grande
affiliation religieuse où les gens vont
à l'église de façon beaucoup plus
structuré que ici par exemple mais c'est
quand même moi je le vois d'un point de
vue plus positif ou demeure une majorité
ça demande une majorité des gens qui
sont en soutien à robbie oued et au
maintien du droit à l'avortement mais
c'est vraiment
si c'est la cause principale au final de
la réticence l'avortement si la ferveur
religieuse états unis où il yad'autres
l'affiliation religieuse devient à être
mélangé avec la politique qui ont eu
donc on l aspect où il ya la
polarisation qui de plus en plus grande
entre les démocrates et les républicains
et que les deux camps sont campés dans
leur ligne puis on ne bouge pas de le
lieu le rôle de effectivement la
religion puis l'activisme et religieux
qui est présent m et on a donc il est le
mélange des deux où on a daily schlatter
qui appartiennent à une des sept
communautés religieuses là qui
transporte dans la loi selon les lignes
de parti
on dirait qu'il ya quelque chose là d'un
tel est
l'importance de la religion dans la
législation pis même à l'intérieur de
législateurs bâti un législateur qui
pourrait écrire une loi basée sur une
idéologie religieuse
ça fait pas ça fait pas de sens dans ma
tête c'est pipi de dire comment sortir
dessus comment essayer d'enlever
complètement la religion des décisions
de législation dans le fond parce qu
elle parce qu'après ça si ça devient
dangereux et de pas d'avoir des
glissements dans cette direction là
dessus oui
mais après c'est que c'est une partie
d'entre terre c'est
là où c'est celle où comment après d'une
personne en froid merkel maintenant
américaine devrait ne peut prendre ces
expériences le par rapport à la façon
dont on aborde la loi c'est une sa
marque identitaire qui est très fort et
qui vient aussi avec des aspects de
conception du monde en fait que même si
on n'est pas l'étiquette religion dessus
ça vient avec la façon dont on aborde le
monde parce que ça l'était entrer dans
l'éducation parce qu'on était élevée
sont en hébreu oui mais de l'autre côté
des métaux si on prend l'exemple du
catholicisme mail à la valeur de
d'engager avec les autres et d'inde et
l'autre
où est ce qu'on met la ligne entre si
une valeur religieuse versus in valeur
il vient d'avoir des
bulles toutes les baies puis on réécrit
un document qui a aucune connotation
religieuse quelque chose comme le guide
du commun bien tenir en société
maintenant comment bien le problème ou
si
ça n'est pas une religion c'est quitter
d'ascq b bluy tout et son contraire on
peut aller chercher ce qui finalement
toi fêtes ont affronté conforte petite
île d'origine
mais puisque je pose la question
naïvement puis peut-être que peut-être
que des concepts le métier dans la bible
comme tels youtube vraiment une ligne
sur l'avortement ou bien si c'est juste
devenu comme la position
du christianisme en général mais ça se
châtient vraiment dans ce sens large et
solide athlète je suis
un commentaire si vous avez lu la bible
parce que tu es si des formes et on
chausse qui sont mis cela sur le dos de
la religion de la région du moins qui
sont des dépositions de la religion qui
finalement tchèque pieds salés et et des
dépôts pas ce qui est et qui là dedans
et par par l'institution par les
traditions qui en a suivi le rôle de
l'interprétation est très intéressant
pour les éléments qui ressort de mes
entretiens actuellement c'est que il ya
la position par exemple que certaines
des participantes vont associer à leur
mère qui dit bébel l'avortement c'est
mal sauf si sa part yves à toi pour toi
on va s'arranger pour que tous les accès
dont il ya aussi cet aspect là qui est
intéressant avec l'opposition là
position des gens sur l'accès à
l'avortement fait que la potion pour soi
versus la position pour les autres puis
l'appartenance religieuse oui mais après
aussi des variations dont appartenance
religieuse entre les différentes les
différents groupes religieux au sein
même de certains groupes pour ne par
exemple sur la question du mariage entre
personnes de même sexe aux états unis et
des églises qui sont en faveur du
mariage entre personnes de même sexe
donc la question d'interprétation epr
est prépondérante il ya un groupe aux
états unis qui s'appelle le relais
jusqu'au la chine ferait d'actifs ce qui
en fait un groupe de gens du milieu de
religieux qui sont en faveur de l'accès
à l'avortement est en faveur de l'accès
au choix donc c'est un petit bémol que
je voulais faire parce que c'est pas
tous les gens vont à l'église qui ont
nécessairement une opposition droit à
l'avortement mais ça l'a été quelques
chose qui vraiment très prépondérant
pour des fins de recherche je suis allé
dans une messe ou dans le sud du texas
donc à brownsville et on approchait de
pâques et donc du fameux 40 jours pour
la vie qui est un mouvement le qui
partent aux états unis qui dira des
bronches et 10 ramifications
internationales maintenant est que
pendant 40 jours on veut prier devant
des cliniques d'avortement pour pour
demander à ce que ça fasse
et je lis recrute des bd jean pendant la
messe ne sait pas tout le monde qui est
vivement en faveur de ça mais il ya le
lien entre les deux parce que il ya une
partie des
gens qui sont très croyants qui font
partie du mouvement du choix mais il
n'avait pas dire que toutes les
personnes croyantes sont ils pourraient
préciser tu disais que tant
qu'etat thèse avait aussi une mec qui
avaient une portée active d'activisme
quand même
qu'est ce qu'on fait à partir de même
les typologies par la vidéo on leur met
délicat comment est-ce que onze en tant
que société des gens probablement que la
plupart des gens qui nous écoutent ont
un peu le même la même pensée une zone
sur ces questions là comment on fait
pour essayer de
redresser le chariot puis c'est pas
tomber dans cette pente glissante
l'appui de rester surtout attentifs
j'imagine qu'évidemment aller voter
quand c'est le temps de voter toutes ces
choses le système s'est classé clos mais
comment est ce qu'on fait pour essayer
de se protéger de cette possibilité que
dans 20 ans on se retrouve avec des
droits en avortement vraiment restreint
ou moins de 20 ans même mes chances que
ça revient un peu à la discussion avait
pourquoi les anti choix sont un peu plus
actifs que les pro chavez parce que on a
l'impression qu'en fait c'est un droit
qui est acquis que ce sera jamais enlevé
que c'est là pour rester et puis c'est
cette idée là en fait qui fait qu'on est
potes
on n'est pas aussi attentifs à ces
petits moments d'érosion du droit parce
que ça t'est venue d'une façon ou abc
c'est une loi c'est une autre loi là
maintenant on se ramasse avec un cadre
législatif qui fait que tellement
d'obstacles que oui le droit est encore
là mais accéder au droit s'est rendu
quasi impossible donc de oui allez voter
évidemment mais aussi de peut prendre
pour acquis ces droits là ce n'est pas
parce que on ne accéder au droit à
l'avortement ou à l'époque sa peau est
valable pour n'importe quel autre droit
social mais dès le moment où il ya un
mouvement de ressac contre ce droit leur
faut pas considérer que c'est un
mouvement qui est marginal qui arrivera
jamais à rien faire puis en fait d'être
toujours en alerte par rapport à celui
de ne peut considérer que c'est un
équipe qu'il n'y aura jamais rien qui va
se passer parce que c'est un peu
stressant fait qui se passe actuellement
est il tellement d'érosion qu'on arrive
en loi comme esb et 8 qui remet en cause
directement au viread et qui pourrait
entraîner la fin de la faim l'accès à
l'avortement aux états unis mais que ça
pourrait entraîner un renversement de
rovi oued et on retournera donc à cette
situation où selon les états ont décidé
au niveau des états donc à peu près une
trentaine d'états aux états unis il se
serait interdit une vingtaine d'états ce
serait les gardent une trentaine où il
serait interdit parce qu'a fait il ya
dans une
graumann emprunteurs qui serait content
la majorité des états
la majorité des électeurs républicains
en fait le goat maca institute qui par
un think tank de recherche aux états
unis sur les droits reproductifs produit
à chaque année une carte des états unis
et class classe les étals comme étant
très favorable jusqu'à très hostile au
droit à l'avortement il ya trente et
actuellement sur 50 qui sont considérés
comme hostiles ou très hostile au droit
à l'avortement et dans la majorité de
ces trente jdle il ya des lois qu'on
appelle des trigger l'a donc des lois
qui sont adoptées qui dit explicitement
si robbie white tombe
l'avortement est illégal dans notre état
donc à partir du moment où la cour
suprême rentrée une opinion qui renverse
rovi wade l'avortement serait rendu
illégal lancées était là et c'est là où
à l'inversé des auteurs qui favorise le
droit à l'avortement qui eux l'ont des
lois inverse le temps que si je tombe ça
reste légale dans notre état donc on se
retrouve dans cette situation le oui à
30 heures tout ce avec une majorité des
américains qui sont pros joueurs qui
sont en faveur qu'il revit wade risque
est qu'avec pas dire qu'ils sont
nécessairement activement pro choix et
c'est là où là lorsqu'on des composants
très doux en faveur de l'avortement dans
tous les cas certains cas où vit la
majorité se retrouvant dans certains cas
donc ça veut pas dire que c'est des gens
qui sont activement pro joie en mixant
savoir que revive adresse est ce que
cette
ce débalancement là entre le nombre
d'êtres qui rendrait l'avortement
illégal versus la majorité qui sont pour
que robbie wade reste est ce que ça
s'explique juste parce que ceux des
milieux urbains qui sont balisés de qui
sont pour que l'avortement les enfants
j'imagine que c'est la concentration des
gens qui sont plus dans des étapes
progressiste ya l'aspect de
concentration d'un sur les deux côtes
des états unis mais il ya quand même
dans des états comme le texas et dix
villes qui sont plus progresser cela dit
il ya des gens qui même s'il vote
républicain ça veut pas dire que sur cet
enjeu là ils sont peu
ils reconnaissent pas qu'il vivrait
devrait rester par exemple ne serait-ce
que si on revient à l'argument avant
rovi oued thérapeutique vers se choisit
il ya des gens qui sont en faveur de
rovi wade pour la protection par rapport
au viol et l'inceste
donc c'est là où il ya aussi la
distinction mais effectivement le lourd
score dès qu'on pose au niveau des états
c'est sûr que les états plus républicain
ya moins de soutien rovi oued que dans
des états plus progressistes et
lorsqu'on regarde la concentration
démographique mais effectivement il sur
les côtes il ya quand même une
concentration de la population mais le
texas et la deuxième étant en terme de
population et donc lorsqu'on regarde
dans les villes comme austin comme el
paso
et même à dhaleh ce qui est quand même
plus républicain que les autres mais qui
quand même et est une grande ville mais
il ya quand même plus de soutien que
lorsqu'on regarde dans le nord du texas
là le boc qui plus rurales
[Rires]
toi j'imagine que dans dans le cadre de
ses recherches
dans des conversations avec des gens qui
sont pros ont le choix
pas beaucoup par le quai je dirais que
on est quand même même si on est des
chercheurs on est quand même étiqueté
aussi avec certaines positions c'est à
dire que oui j'ai des participantes à ma
recherche qui s'identifie comme étant
anti choix mais
mais en fait c'est que mon marché en
deux temps il ya une partie qui en ligne
qui est un questionnaire puis une partie
qui est une entrevue puis
majoritairement les as en portant les
gens qui sont contre le droit à
l'avortement refuse de faire l'entrevue
a pris et donc font la première partie
mais veulent pas en parler dans le
second temps parce qu'ils connaissent
tongi mes billets ou mais je pense que
la position
ouest recherches google avec mon âge
où je me trouvais sur la question mais
par contre sur le terrain lorsque
j'avais derrière le paso
c'est une ville démocrates d'une ville
qui votent démocrate le better work
vient de el paso donc c'est une ville
qui est frontalière avec le mexique et
moi j'allais le avec peu
une idée des villes démocrates du sud en
me disant belge ces démocrates lexique
arrêt que je peux dire ce sur quoi je
travaille paie pas de problème quand je
suis arrivé là en fait je se rendre
compte que même à l'université je
pouvais pas dire sur quoi je travaille
est il fallait que j'utilise des mots
différents donc je ne travaillais pas
sur l'accès à l'avortement quand
j'habitais là bas je travaillais sur
l'accès aux soins de santé reproductive
donc
changement de terme l'offre en sorte que
sur le terrain mais ça passe mieux puis
on peut avoir des discussions puis pour
moi c'est vraiment important d'avoir des
discussions c'est avec les gens qui sont
anti choix parce que ça explique aussi
leur perception de l'accessibilité à
l'avortement qui ce sur quoi je
travaille pièce que l'état devrait avoir
des lois plus restrictives - moins
restrictive parce que vous percevez
comme l'avortement comme étant
extrêmement facile d'accessibilité ou
pas selon où on se trouve au fait ce
spectre idéologique là mais ça peut
influencer la façon dont on perçoit
l'accessibilité donc pour moi c'est
important mais c'est plus difficile à
recruter
commenta proche des discussions là parce
que tu es toi de ton côté tu es capable
d'expliquer mettons c'est quoi les
conséquences de
deux de moins d'accès à l'avortement
c'est une conséquence sur quels groupes
déjà marginalisés des conséquences
économiques de tout ce qu'il ya des
arguments
tangibles et quantifiables mesurable
quand même tu es à ce handicap confronte
à quelqu'un que pour lui c'est plus une
question idéologique c'est plus bas
notamment c'est mal ou ont une vie
normale à
l'éduction et du possible nous est
impossible
moi quand j'essaie de disques sur l'âge
et pas une discussion comme j'aurai une
discussion avec des amis ou j'essaie de
convaincre l'autre personne de mon point
de vue en fait c'est une discussion en
tant que chercheur qui fait du terrain
d'observation donc mon objectif dans ce
disque sur le spot convaincre l'autre
personne ou de dire que ça sa position
et peut valoir en fait d'écouter puis de
de comprendre
d'où vient cette position-là 2 surtout
parce que moi je travaille avec la
communauté latino-américaine qu'il ya un
très gros tabou entourant l'accès à
l'avortement donc des fois c'est une
question de comment la personne a été
éduquée est ce qu on a beaucoup de liens
avec la famille au mexique ou pas le
rôle de la religion quand une fois dans
le quotidien donc pour moi c'est tout
des éléments qui permet de comprendre le
positionnement idéologique de quelqu'un
qui sait sur quoi je travaille en fait
donc il mon objectif dans ces
discussions là c'est pas du tout de
convaincre de dire ça c'est bien ça
c'est mal mais je sais juste d'écouter
en fait puis de d'engager une discussion
pour que l'autre personne parle de ses
positions mais moi je parle jamais de
mes positions à moi quand je te défendre
revue du s est pas et c'est pas comme si
je prends un verre avec des amis
une discussion par rapport à mon point
de vue personnel mais recherché il ya
une part d'activistes dans les
recherches parce que je travaille sur un
long jeu qui aussi prenant que
l'objectif pour moi c'est pas que ma
thèse soit table et et puis que moi et
mode rector soient les seules personnes
à l'avoir il essaie une fois que ma
thèse doit être produite mon objectif
moi c'est de produire également
deux pages de les plus grands de médée
conclusion principale puis da aider les
organismes qui défendent le droit à
l'avortement sur le terrain avoir des
statistiques sur les femmes latino
américaine sur l'accessibilité défend
maintenant 1000 km dans les contextes
frontaliers donc c'est le la part
d'activistes parce que j'ai une volonté
de diffuser les résultats de ma
recherche mais dans le dos mais
entretient mon objectif n'est pas du
tout de beaucoup de convaincre ni de
laisser paraître mon positionnement
stade en question on me cherche sur
internet pour retrouver ma page twitter
qui reste à voir mais si on se parlait
comme celui que j'étais dans la position
de chercheurs bas les questions que je
rentre elle vous posez ce serait pas
possible de savoir est ce que moi je
suis en faveur ou en défaveur du droit à
l'avortement
mais l'autre jour j'ai j'avais eu une
discussion avec un groupe d'amis puis
c'était la première fois mais je me sens
presque naïvement j'imagine je croyais
que la
être pro choix c'est comme si tu es en
bas dans ma génération mais ton mitigé
jamais été confrontée à
une idée opposée à celle jusqu'à
dernièrement parce que je parlais avec
un groupe d'amis prêts à mener la
question a été abordée à cause justement
des récents événements est exact que
j'ai réalisé qui a finalement ce que je
croyais être comme une évidence même
était même pas un acquis à 100% ici au
québec avec des gens de notre génération
l'outil fait campagne en 2008 projet
comme
pas vraiment super je n'avais jamais
réfléchi d'habitude quand jouer
argumenté que quelqu'un je lui ai fait
une couple de fois dans mon char à voix
haute dans la grille à la plage pour
pratiquer un peu une coupe de tourneur
de
l'avortement guy me demande maintenant
des questions surtout depuis j'y réponds
comme si j'ai une idée préconçue ce ma
façon de réfléchir à vos dons mais
j'avais jamais même fait cette démarche
là pour cette question là parce que je
me dis ça va jamais je n'aurais jamais
besoin de parler de ça n'importe qui le
dit j'aurais pas cette déduction l'appui
au final j'ai réalisé que ok nantes
après puis c'est là en plus avec tout
tout l'accumulation de comme ce qui se
passe aux etats unis les
députés conservateurs puis un appui
quand même qu'il serait possible auprès
des jeunes québécois j'ai fait attaquer
notre pays il quelque chose
c'est là où c'est intéressant parce que
ça renvoie à l'idée de tantôt qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire mais si on prend pour
acquis que c'est un droit y en a qui est
un droit qui est ici pied c'est une
posture en fait qui est informé par
notre génération qui est informé aussi
par notre statut socioéconomique par
notre jeunesse nos culturel parce que
pour nous en fait il n'y a jamais eu de
de questionnements des ce que c'est un
droit ou pas et on enix était un droit
au canada où
d'arboucave phillips était inférieur
droit donc j'ai pas eu ces
questionnements le ppi est
historiquement et notre groupe est né
culturel pas été visée par des pratiques
de stérilisation forcée par exemple par
d'autres pratiques de contrôle de la
santé reproductive qui fait qu'on serait
plus plus au fait de ces enjeux le ou
qu'on remettra en cause de kim et
peut-être que ça va nous être enlevé à
un moment ou un autre le dock c'est une
posture aussi où on eu un privilège de
concert comme étant un droit mais qu'on
doit remettre en cause ce parce que ça
ce point que ce soit plus un droit qu'on
est en train d'apprendre d'abord aux
états unis exact l'addiction ne sais
quoi c'est quoi la position c'est
l'argumentaire maintenant
l'argumentaire c'était que
je peux aller en profondeur j'ai
rapidement changé mais c'était
qu'initialement la de l'acte sexuel
était
en prenant la décision d'avoir un an de
faire un acte sexuel tu veux mais tu es
tu savais que c'était une possibilité de
conclusion mettons fait que en sachant
se décider quand même de prendre
part à une relation sexuelle en sachant
qu'il y avait une des possibilités que
c'était ce qu'il fallait qu'ils soient
prêts à vivre avec la conclusion de tes
choix mettons le fait que ce test est le
début de la conversation qui j'imagine
n'était que la pointe de l'iceberg
comme si j'étais allé plus loin dans la
conversation s'arrête pas été justement
ton sauf que j'ai l'impression que ce
serait comme la halle le début qu'ils
aient fait que j'aime me suis dit ok
quelqu'un quelque chose là que ça me
tente pas de briser le bail ble goude
potro d'aller vers le fait que non c'est
s appuie mais c'est sûr que je reste un
peu surpris puisque je me suis joint par
la guilde
télégraphie et les autres à l'atome on
n'a pas souvent performer mungo
jamais à porter
mais tant que les gens qui nous écoutent
ils veulent
de suivi veulent savoir rester à l'affût
mettant tout ce que tu nous a parlé je
pense que là ce que tu dis là c'est le
1er décembre qui va avoir une un vrai
test à la cour suprême
les gens qu'est ce qu'ils font pour
suivre sur de suivre ce soit moi j'ai
quand même très active sur twitter par
rapport à ces enjôleurs donc chaque fois
qu'ils aient quelque chose qui sort sur
les enjeux je vais soit partagée des
articles voire même faire les fameux
retrait donc d'une multitude de truies
président d'expliquer
mais
je trouve que c'est important puisque
c'est un des rôles quand nos milieux
académiques quand on fait de la
recherche mais si peu juste de faire des
recherches pour parler dans le cadre de
l'université pour moi c'est important de
vulgariser ce que je fais parce que
comme je dis à mon sujet une composante
très actuel et à un peu active et soucis
donc je disais fait le meilleur moyen de
de suivre ces développements le citron
le réseau social que j'utilise le plus
d'un point de vue professionnel
confirmant que vous vouliez voir des
cafés
lincoln au dessus on va mettre le 30
watts heure dans la destruction de ce
podcast parce que s que les conclusions
ce qui était déjà une idée des
conclusions petit tir de ton travail ou
t'es pas encore rendu de lanton
processus m j'ai pas encore rendus là
pleinement c'est à dire que bon ça fait
un mois et demi que j'ai commencé les
entretiens et puis moi je fais partie
des chercheurs qui sont créées qui met
beaucoup l'emphase sur les entretiens
sur l'important parfaite du terrain puis
de que la recherche découle en fait de
ce qui se passe sur le terrain et non
pas de tenter de confirmer ou infirmer
disparu
mais à date je dirais que peu importe
l'endroit où se situent les femmes entre
les quatre étapes j'étudie il ya
vraiment un enjeu par rapport à
l'information disponible donc est ce que
les états donnent une information qui
est juste et qui faisait republic ou est
ce qu'il ya vraiment un enjeu
idéologique par rapport à l'information
qui diffusait et avec ça il ya aussi de
la question de la langue très sûr la
communauté latino-américaine donc est ce
que l'information est accessible en
espagnol ou en anglais sa teinte aussi
le niveau de connaissances sur ce
l'aspect du tabou donc ce que le la
prépondérance du tabou tant au niveau de
la communauté elle même que dans l'état
où la femme habite peut avoir une
incidence sur sa conception de
l'accessibilité à l'avortement et le
troisième c'est vraiment le
positionnement géographique mais moi je
travaille en géopolitique les donc le
rapport territoire pouvoir et dans une
perspective féministe donc les corps
donc où est ce qu'une femme se situe
temps sur le territoire des etats-unis
mais même à l'intérieur d'un état va
avoir une grande incidence sur sa vision
de l'accessibilité à l'avortement et sa
capacité d'accéder aux soins si el
detter mettre un terme à une grossesse
non actuellement un mois et demi dans
les eaux traitées c'est là où je
m'enligne preures parler dans un encart
la nike
fait merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir écouté ce podcast jusqu'à
la fin de ce pas que vous avez apprécié
la conversation ça prouve que vous êtes
de réelles fans de conversation et sans
fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup si vous voulez voir
plus de contenus plus de conversations
sur pétillante que ça se passe il ya
surper tués a non seulement on mettre
tous les podcasts en ligne au moment où
est ce qu'on les tombes donc on a
beaucoup de semaine d'avant sur le
pétrole mais on fait aussi des encore
moins de filtres qui sont exclusifs au
monde pictural ou est ce que on parle
d'homme nicole et moi de la conversation
combien d'abord parce qu'on met un peu
plus en profondeur dans certains sujets
complets abordés ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast donc allez sur une
page de turenne les le lien vers savoir
dans la description du podcast qui
remercie encore une fois de nous avons
écouté jusqu'à la fonte